it's hard to shop for PC gamers there's
just so many dang peripherals out there
that's why we've done the hard work for
you this is GameSpot's Holiday Gift
Guide for the PC gamer any respectable
PC gamer is gonna use a mechanical
keyboard a membrane one simply won't do
Coursera makes a pretty respectable one
$400 in its k68 which offers red
switches this means it has a linear
tactile field that's smooth to the touch
it's also dust and water resistant in
case you spill a little eggnog on your
keyboard it's gonna be okay any
respectable keyboard is gonna need an
awesome mouse to go with it I'll just
take make some of the best mice in the
world and we're gonna recommend the
company's G 403 it cost around $70 and
comes with a state-of-the-art optical
sensor for around $30 more you can also
get the wireless version 2g 703 which is
also great as well while nothing beats
the keyboard and nos for shooters some
games will just play better with a
controller while the xbox360 controller
was a mainstay for many PC gamers for a
long time because of its X input support
it has since been surpassed by the Xbox
one controller which offers better
analog sticks new variants of this
controller will also support bluetooth
which means you can play wireless
without a dongle for your audio needs
we're recommending hyper X's cloud alpha
headset not only is it really
comfortable but they sound great it also
comes with a detachable mic and you can
also use it with your phone if your
phone supports an audio jack for our
gaming monitor we're picking LG's ultra
wide panel with its 21 by 9 aspect ratio
it almost gives you an unfair advantage
in games that support it it also offers
a 5 millisecond response time which is
super quick it also comes with an IPS
panel which means it offers vivid colors
and a wide viewing angles best of all
you can get it for under 200 bucks if
you'd rather spend your time in Virtual
Reality rather than looking at a flat
monitor and we've got a recommendation
for you with the oculus rift dropping
down a price to $400 now is the best
time to get into VR to power that VR
headset you're gonna need a capable
video card that's why we're recommending
the GTX 1060 you can find variants of
Nvidia graphics cards for around $200 it
also happens to be a great car for
maxing out most games at 1080p PC gamers
I want to see them on sites like twitch
are going to need a good way
camp that's why we're recommending a
Logitech c920 - it can shoot at 1080p at
30 frames per second or 720p at 60
frames per second it also shoots well in
low-light conditions to take your
streams to the next level
you'll want a high quality microphone
the blue Yeti happens to be the industry
standard and for a good reason it allows
you to record in bi-directional
omnidirectional and more also it just
happens to sound really great so those
are our picks for the PC Gamer for more
holiday gift guides make sure to head on
over to gamespot.com thank you for
watching